I'm ranking every fire user in anime
from Crazy Fire Breathing girlfriends
like this here to characters with such
powerful fire that they might as well be
gods and in a bit of a Twist right out
of the gate I'm going to put the captain
Commander yamama Molle from bleach in
the god tier right away because he is
one of the absolute strongest fire users
in all of anime I mean his fire is
literally as hot as the core of the Sun
which is pretty Godlike if you ask me
but to keep the surprises coming right
away I'm actually going to show you
exactly how many characters are as
strong or maybe even stronger than
Yamamoto in the gods here right here
because including him there are 10 of
these absolute fire wielding powerhouses
who I think are clearly above every
other fire user in all of anime now who
could all these characters be well they
are all going to be extraordinary fire
users but first let's shift down from
the god tier to the next strongest tier
which is the dust tier now I'll admit
that this is a bit of a strange name but
basically to be in this tier Your Flames
have to be so incredibly powerful that
they can literally turn an enemy into a
pile of Ash and really what better
character to start this tier off than
genos from one punch man whose insation
cannons can literally obliterate
opponents and leave nothing behind and
we might as well continue introducing
the next tier so next up is the generic
overpowered anime fire users tier that
is a bit of a mouthful to say maybe I
should have just called it the generic
tier after all and starting off this
tier we have Magna swing from Black
Clover who like most of the characters
in this tier can basically summon fire
at will and toss it around to attack his
opponents not the most powerful but
still very decently strong enough for
his own story however Magna swing might
as well be a god level character
compared to this next tier which is the
poof tier and essentially these are
fairly weak fire users at least compared
to the rest ones on this list and to
start off this tier we're going to go
way back in the history of anime to
Sailor Moon yes and this truly was one
of the OG shows at least outside of
Japan and here saor Mars is the fire
using princess but if I'm being honest
she is pretty weak I mean her strongest
attack is flame sniper but even this
move isn't powerful enough to take out
any strong opponents which honestly it's
kind of crazy that Sailor Moon is even
above this final bottom tier which I'm
going to call the barely counts as a
fire user tier and the perfect example
of this is bals from akaa Kill and so
while bals is surprisingly a pretty nice
person he has done some truly horrible
things such as inserting entire villages
with his superpowered flamethrower
however since he can't actually make
fire himself he does fall into this
bottom tier which brings us to what
might already be the most controversial
ranking in the entire video and that's
because we're going to put Madar from
Naruto right here now before every
single mad fan types angrily in the
comments below one thing to keep in mind
is that I'm ranking these characters
most based on their fir Powers not
necessarily all of a character's
overpowered abilities and while in
general m is without any doubt a god
tier level fighter his strongest fire
attack ultimate fire release is a wide
ranging attack that ultimately was able
to be fairly easily blocked by many
Ninja so that drops him down from God to
dust tier at least as a fire user but
while the master Ninja can burst out in
Flames this next character is a literal
fire breathing monster and of course I'm
talking about Charizard from Pokemon
whose mega X and Y Transformations make
him one of the more powerful monsters in
all of Pokemon plus he's just a personal
favorite of mine so don't complain that
these transformation aren't all in the
anime this is my tier list at the moment
so I can do what I want with it bam dust
tier even though they did make him into
a fluffy toy but that doesn't matter and
speaking of fluffy toys do you know who
also needs a hug well that's going to be
this guy right here escanor from the
seven deadly sins who is also the second
person of our god tier and that's
because during the night he becomes a
whiny weakling who could sure use some
support but during High Noon In The Sun
oh boy this man becomes the literal sun
god whose blazing sun powers can make
even the Demon King look like some kind
of slime tier character Mr the one is
god tier for sure but even he would run
like crazy from Kyoko kirisaki from
black hat who is so crazy that she's
going to invent a whole brand new tier
for this video and we're going to call
this the Crazy Fire Breathing girlfriend
tier and kitty Zaki definitely deserves
to be here because she prefers to defeat
her opponents by kissing them and then
burning them from the
inside is uh swipe left for me that is
and and while kizaki might freak you out
of as well at least she can't literally
burn your soul like R oami from
codebreaker in fact his Flames are so
strong that turning someone into Ash is
easy and his most powerful attack can
even burn an enemy's Soul so that they
can never commit another crime in their
entire life which does earn him a solid
place in dust here and my vote for him
to become police chief for sure which
might actually make this next ranking
here a little bit controversial because
he from yuu Haku show uses his dark
Flames to become our next god tier level
fire user and you may not even know that
these evil looking Flames here can
destroy anything in their path including
people and buildings and while this is
kind of similar to what ogami does as
well who we just put in the dust here to
me he has flames are just so much on
another level altogether that we just
have to rank him in the gatier but
that's three gotier Fire characters
already and we still have seven left to
go plus a ton of other fantastic
characters never ranked your favorite
fire user yet because if not let's knock
out some of the lower tier characters in
one go first is bakugo from my hero
Academia and while his explosions are
incredibly powerful they only earn him a
place in the generic tier because as
usual he gets the side character
treatments and I do hate to say it but
I'm also going to put his classmate
Shoto Todoroki in the same tier as well
which I do still think is pretty fair
because I mean he can only truly unlock
his strongest fire if he balances it
with his ice powers plus as we've seen
recently in the manga he couldn't even
100% take out another of the fire users
that we still see later on in this
ranking from his same story and if
that's not bad enough to ruffle even
more feathers let's discuss Ace and Sao
from One Piece because they both have
the same fire devil fruit Powers but I'm
going to rank one higher than the other
and let's actually start with Ace who
unlike other characters on this list is
literally made off fire that means that
normal attacks just pass right through
him and he can summon huge amounts of
fire to create super powerful attacks
and so because of this and maybe because
of a little bit of a personal bias I'm
going to put him in dust tier yeah did
you think I was going to put him in god
tier even I have to be somewhat honest
for these rankings so yeah we can't do
that but it does leave us with Sabo and
the big question is does he go above or
below Ace well in my personal opinion
reusing the same Powers as Ace is not as
impressive to me so even though Sabo is
arguably stronger because of his other
fighting abilities I'm still going to
rank him down here in the generic tier
for now and I'll be honest this next
character was going to be right beside
Sao here in the generic tier and that's
because Phoenix II's powers are pretty
standard I'd say fire blasts fire
punches we know the deal but then I
remembered two things first this anime
came out over 35 years ago which is
actually way before I was even born
which means me that we have to ask
ourselves if we can really call these
Powers generic if II was one of the
first mainstream characters to use them
in the first place plus because he has
the powers of the Phoenix every time he
dies he comes back to life even stronger
so good luck ever killing him and all
this means that I have no other choice
but to make him our fourth god tier
level character now nzuko from Demon
Slayer is another character that I was
kind of torn back and forth between now
on the one hand her blood-based fir
Powers have honestly never really
defeated anyone on their own they're
more support powers to help her brother
plus they do only affect demons so at
first I was kind of thinking of putting
her into the poof tier but because her
powers are pretty unique and can deal
some very serious damage to even the
strongest demons I will bump her up to
the generic tier now this next character
showing up on this tier list might shock
you a little bit and that's because Levi
from Black Lagoon isn't really a fire
user she actually just uses guns and
explosives very well I might add but
this is a fire tier list and there's
more than one kind of fire if you know
what I mean so we'll make her own
special tier called the technically not
a fire but still a fire user tier just
for her and actually another character
who fire you definitely don't want to
mess with is my superpowered kitty Gojo
whose fire blast will surely take over
the world unless you stop him by
pressing that big red subscribe button
and next in the dust tier is possibly
the most popular character on this list
Roy Mustang the flame Alchemist has an
unbelievable knowledge of fire Alchemy
so much so that with a single snap of
his fingers he can create super accurate
and destructive fire blasts and really
the only thing actually holding him back
from Gods here is that his powers are
harder to use in the rain although
technically he can separate the water
molecules and light the oxygen on fire
by using a complex reaction using all
the
terminal all right sorry back to the
tier list now while Mustang is clearly a
fire genius Ayano kanagi from kazeno
stigma can barely control her magical
Crimson flame which does land her in the
poof tier and if you are an avid Anime
Watcher you might have noticed that
there are characters from one particular
anime that we haven't ranked yet and of
course I know what you're going to say
it is of course fire force which is a
show literally all about fire and we
could probably put almost every
character in fire force on this list but
that would take way too long so instead
we're going to name just a few of them
and what better way to start than with
our fifth god tier character Leonard
Burns seriously this man's power levels
can get off the charts his ability is
called voltage Nova which basically lets
him continuously heat up his body giving
him a huge buff in physical strength and
durability the longer it stays active he
just brushes off explosions with ease
and can literally melt fireproof
clothing just by walking by but now
there are only five GS tier characters
left and do you think you know who they
are but even burns doesn't get as crazy
as these next three characters and
that's because I'm going to drop another
special tier called the pyromaniacs for
those fire users who are just a little
bit messed in the head if you know what
I mean and I just had to keep them
together in the script because leaving
them alone could lead to them setting
the whole script on fire and we do not
want that the first of these is the fire
lightning princess Azula from Avatar who
shoots off lightning blasts like a kid
at a carnival game and right next to her
is dbby from my hero Academia who has
burned himself so much that he had to
replace his own skin he's just
completely unhinged which you would
especially know if you've read the
recent events in the manga which you
should and the final member of this
pyromaniacs tier is going to be myawa
from obyo who has pretty standard firep
Powers but is just such an evil dude who
just likes to watch his enemies burn to
a crisp now luckily for us the person
who actually defeated miyagawa is is up
next and that is teruki hanazawa also
from mobo however Teru is a man of many
talents and for him fire is basically a
sight hustle since he can also use a ton
of other psychic abilities like force
field explosions air whips and more but
if we're just strictly talking about his
firep powers he's pretty average so he's
just going to go into the generic tier
like for example tii would stand no
chance against this next character and
that's because Gabi Maru from hell's
Paradise is an explosive flame erupting
Ninja who can burn his enemies to a
crisp and while you might say that his
powers aren't anything super special I
just love the fact that his powers are
so op that when he is close to dying he
unlocks a fiery berserk mode that can
even damage Gods definitely deserving of
at least the dust tier and now this next
character takes that to an even higher
level unveiling the six god tier fire
user we have faton from Hunter Hunter
because even though he isn't even a pure
fire user his ultimate attack turns all
of the damage he has taken into a
blistering Rising Sun that literally
destroyed an entire Fortress and I'll
say that that by itself deserves God's
tier in my opinion however one other
character that didn't quite make the
goder cut was Alibaba from Magi whose
impressive looking flame ministers
beheading sword is pretty remarkable and
can easily take out weaker enemies but
just didn't do quite enough for me to
put him any higher than the Dust here
and actually the same can be said for
Joo from juk kaisen who has some pretty
incredible Feats as well he can for
example create a whole volcanic
Dimension and his strongest attack from
the manga can bring down a massive
flaming meteor that can destroy an
entire city block which might have
earned him gottier except for what
happened against the next character and
a brief manga spoiler warning here but
when Joo fought sukuna the cursed Spirit
was defeated by this which I mean what
is this I mean technically sukuna is not
even supposed to be able to use fire in
the first place so where the heck do we
rank this guy got tier rarely counts
tier I really don't know so let's just
make his own we don't know what the heck
this is tier because I'm allowed to do
that right well anyways now we've been
dealing with some quite intense Flames
for quite a while so let's simmer down a
little bit with Hellfire flame from one
punch man in the poof tier and this
sword wielding monster can kick and
slash with flames so if you're into FY
swordsman you might want to check him
out and right below him is how asakura
from Shaman King and even though asakura
is basically the most powerful character
in the entire show he is only so
powerful because he fights by summoning
Elemental spirits to fight for him which
why we're going to put him in the barely
counts tier however no one can say that
this next character doesn't fight on his
own and his fir powers are like no one
else's on this list because this is
shishio Makoto from the legendary
Samurai anime rudoni Kenshin now this
dude is a an incredible swordsman but
his flame Powers actually come from a
pretty horrifying Source you see Makoto
soaked his sword in the oily fat of
countless opponents so that now his
sword can catch on fire whenever he
wants that's pretty awful if you ask me
but still cool to watch him duel with
Kenshin and if sworts aren't your thing
though how about a giant fire breathing
dog well that is exactly what we get
with Pluto from Black Butler and while
he certainly isn't generic I don't think
he is extremely powerful either so he's
going to go into the poof tier which now
leads us to probably the single most
generic fire user in this entire ranking
which is Mikoto Su from the K anime yeah
that's right that show is literally
called K and he can basically use his
Aura to create heat blasts and probably
even help him keep that sulky glare on
his face 24/7 which by the way is
basically the same expression that we
get from our seventh god tier character
Sasuke from Naruto and as you you can
see we're clearly ranking him above
Madar which may trigger the Naruto fans
here but in my opinion he has such a
Mastery of his special Amaterasu Flames
that he just has to be in the G here
because these super unique Flames will
only burn what SASE wants but if he
truly lets them lose they won't stop
burning until there is nothing left of
his enemy and while admittedly they
didn't really work on Madara they are
super op against basically anybody else
this means that if Sasuke is in GTI then
his brother Itachi must be dust here and
the Naruto fan base is going to go
insane but kind of using the same logic
as with Sabo and Ace both of the
brother's strongest Flames are maasu but
since Sasuke uses them better than his
brother I'd say I'm just going to have
to rank Itachi a little bit below Sasuke
oh and if you're feeling bad for Itachi
maybe we should plop him down with
kisaki into the Crazy Fire girlfriend
tier to cheer him up no okay well we're
just going to have to do another
addition into this tier and that's going
to be C E from dat alive which is
basically a fire Spirit but not just any
fire spirit because she can transform
her arm into a flaming axe or even an
overpowered flame Cannon because I mean
I guess why not and meuman from konos
SOA is another fire powerered girl but
she ends up in the poof tier because her
fire spells quickly drain her Mana power
which leaves her relying on her allies
most of the time and actually you'll
never believe that our next gotier
character was actually a contender for
the strongest fire user ever because
this is Bim Maru from fire force whose
Crimson Moon attack against this fire
demon literally took my breath away I
mean wow what a super impressive power
for one of the strongest fire users in
the story and now we've only got two
goder characters left to go and I'll
just warn you they might be even
stronger than benimaru but before we get
into those top dogs though we have Vin
Okumura from Blue Exorcist who uses his
Supernatural blue flames and skills to
wipe out the royalty of the demon worlds
however perhaps his most impressive feat
is that he created a fire attack
powerful enough to take out the impure
King demon all while leaving his friends
Untouched by the magical blue flames
pretty impressive stuff if you ask me
which does land him a solid spot in the
dust here and yet another character with
blue flames that we're putting in dust
here is starjun from toico this Master
Chef and Gourmet Hunter can create
flames hot enough to MK too's iron
silverware attacks and even produced
giant flame slashes that can create
massive holes in the earth and while Ren
and star jun's blue flames are awesome
to look at this next characters fire is
some of the prettiest in all of anime
because this is Julie rist field from
asterisk War who summons fire with the
imagery of flowers quite nice if you ask
me but good looks only get you only so
far in this ranking so down to the poof
tier it is for you which does bring us
to tazuki from the anime Fushigi Yugi
which is honestly a pretty powerful
Fighter EX except that all of his firep
powers comes from his magical Tesson fan
which barely counts here for him I guess
and actually if you want another OG
anime that will blow your mind then
check out Rea hanabishi from the flame
of Rea and Rea fully earns his place in
the dust tier because he can summon fire
at will with his strongest attacks using
the power of seven mythical fire dragons
to demolish his enemies however you
cannot talk about classic anime without
mentioning of course JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure which of course has its very
own fire user as well Mohamed abdol
Whose stand power is called magician rat
which does fight with fire and honestly
did have a bit of a trouble ranking him
because he's certainly not dust level
but I do think he would wipe out all of
poof here so even though it does kind of
hurt my very soul to call anyone from
JoJo generic I'm going to drop him into
the generically overpowered tier which
is a better spot than Stella Vermilion
from chivalry of failed night earned
because her fiery sword skills are not
all that impressive especially because
it took her basically the whole anime to
figure out that she had Dragon Powers
now that is poof tier if I've ever seen
one though if you want a character who
is a master of his powers right from the
very start of the show you should check
out steel Magnus From a Certain Magical
Index because this generic tier chains
smoking pyromancer can summon fire with
his magical runes and spells and if he
needs to bust out a strong attack he can
create a fiery monster to help fight
against his opponents but he's not
actually a good guy which can also by
the way be said about Endeavor from my
hero Academia as well because of the way
that he basically seriously traumatized
all of his kids however powerwise
Endeavor is certainly an absolute
Powerhouse of a fighter whose prominence
burn attack can vaporize opponents in an
instant which does earn him a solid
place in the dust tier and so if you
want the perfect person to beat some
responsibility into Endeavor look no
further than M Leona Vermillion from
Black Clover this Noble woman magician
is the captain of a royal Knight Squad
and fights with giant explosive fire
blast which makes her the strongest fire
user in the story and she can certainly
compete with nearly everyone else on
this list and she nearly made it into
goder I think but couldn't quite crack
my top 10 so she'll have to just stay at
the top of the Dust tier however this
next character does in fact Ascend to
godhood and it is natu from fairy tale
because even though he can get stom out
by other elements there are almost no
fire users as strong as this fire eating
monster of a character whose Flames are
so powerful that he can melt Stone just
by walking past it and even take out
monstrous dragons which does leave us
with only one more godier character left
and if you've been wondering all this
time if I was going to leave Shinra off
yet another list well then this one's
out for you because the main character
of fire forest has gotten so strong that
his fire can even allow him to zip
around at light speed and Destroy
opponents with truly massive explosions
and those are just a few of the Godlike
abilities that he unlocks later on in
the manga but sadly we cannot end on the
fiery godliness of shinida because we
have one more character to go and that
is the flame Hasa ringoku from Demon
Slayer now this may come as a shock to
some of you but rengoku is actually not
a fire user technically because while
there was some debate about the
incredible fir powers that we see in the
anime these Flames are
not real they're just a visualization of
the sword skills however they do look so
awesome that we'll have to throw him in
with Levi in the technically not a fire
user but still fire tier but while the
hash's elemental powers might be fake
the Demon's magical abilities in Demon
Slayer are very much real so you can
imagine if Roku was a demon and had
actual firep Powers what that would look
like I mean surely he would become one
of the strongest demons alive right well
if you want to find out how that would
go you can check out that video right
here thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one